اللواء خالد المحجوب الامين العام للقياده
العامه للجيش الليبي كشف ان الحاويات وجدت
في نقطه باتجاه الحدود التشاديه على بعد
خمسه كيلومترات فقط من المستودع الذي كان
البراميل والذي رجح التقارير انه في
مدينه سبها وانتقد المحجوب وكاله الطاقه
بدعوى انها فتشت الموقع في عام 2020
وجردت ما فيه من محتويات ثم اغلقت بابه
بالشمع الاحمر واوضح ان الوكاله تعهدت في
ذلك الوقت بتوفير احتياجات الحراسه التي
تشمل ملابس خاصه وكمامات وغيرها لحمايه
الافراد من اي اخطار المحجوب قال ان
الوكاله لم تفي بتعهداتها ما دفع الحراس
لمراقبه المستودع من نقطه بعيده خوفا من
الاخطار وبحسب المحجوب فان جماعات المسلحه
ربما استغلت الوضع واستولت على البراميل
لكنها كانت تجهل طبيعه الماده الموجوده
فيها فتركتها